[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه نحييكم وهذه
التاسعه
في اولى مباريات نصف نهائي المونديال
الارجنتين بمحارت ميسي تواجه كرواتيا
بخبره
طهران تحكيم على مئات المتظاهرين بالسجن
طويلا وتتواعد بملاحقه دعم الاحتجاجات حول
العالم
جنرال بريطانيه يكشفوا عن مشاركته بحريه
بلاده في عمليات عسكريه الى جانب اوكرانيا
ضد روسيا
الاقصى منذ عشر سنوات اضرابات كبيره تشل
مفاصل بريطانيا والجيش ياخذ وضعيه العمال
[موسيقى]
الارجنتين وكرواتيا او ميسي ومدرج هي
مونديال الفرصه الاخيره بالنسبه للنجمين
العالميين يرفع ميسي صاحب ال 35 عاما رايه
التحدي امام مودريتش صاحب 37 عاما فكلا
النجمين يبحثان عن التاهل
لثاني نهائي مونديال لهما حيث فشل ميسي في
الحضن اللقب عام 2014 ليخسر امام المانيا
بينما سقط مودريتش في نهائي النسخه
الماضيه في روسيا عام 2018 امام فرنسا
بالنسبه لمباراه اليوم اما غدا الاربعاء
فهناك قمه اخرى يلتقي فيها المنتخب
المغربي حاملا امالا كبيرا بنظيره المنتخب
الفرنسي
ولان مشاهدينا الى الدوحه ومفرد العربيه
ليس قبل انطلاق هذه المباراه كيف هي
الاجواء من هناك طبعا الاجواء حماسيه كنت
برساله الماضيه تقول ان الجماهير
الارجنتينيه هي الطاغيه كيف هي الصوره
الان
نعم
كما تشاهدين عائله ارجنتينيه وصلت قبل
قليل الى هنا الى ملعب الاستاذ خلفي
لمشاهده المباراه بين ارجنتين الارجنتين
وكرواتيا ولكن هم كانوا يعني شبه متاكدين
بان الارجنتين سوف تفوز بهذه المباراه مع
كرواتيا يا استاذ
العاصمه الارجنتينيه
والان هم اللي يحضر المباراه التي ستقام
بعد ساعه ونصف ساعه من الان ولكن
نعم هم اتلوا مشاهده المباراه وبعد ذلك
سيذهبون غدا الى مصر ومن ثم يعودون حتى
الفنان حتى المباراه النهائيه لكاس العالم
ولكن يعني قبل قليل كانوا يحتفلون خلف
الكاميرا عندما عند قرع الطبول في المنطقه
الاخرى
لمواكبه المشجعين المنتخب الارجنتيني همم
من الكرواتيين هنا ولكن انا الارجنتين سوف
يربح هذه المباراه نظرا لكثره المشجعين
الارجنتين وانا كمان تشاهدين هو يداعب
الشخص الذي وصل قبل قليل وهو يرتدي ازاي
الكرواتي
همم
لا يستطيع التوقع كم تكون النتيجه
تسجل اهداف قبل الدقيقه 90 بن الماتش او
المباراه ولكن يعني هم طبعا
بنامس خنتوس واكون امينا همم
وصلوا الى الدوحه في العشرين من نوفمبر
الماضي لمشاهده طبعا لمشاهده الممتاز
والمباريات التي تقام هنا طبعا لكن زوجته
وابنته لاحقات به همم لاحقا ليكون هنا
للمباراه التي ستقام الليله والمباراه
التي ستقام الهلال او النهائي في كاس
العالم رجع ههه شكرا لك ليس على كل حال
هو ايضا يعني يستفز الزملاء هنا وخصوصا
زمانها فاروق
ههه من وراء الكاميرا شكرا
مودريتش
هذه المباراه
اذا حماس وتحدي ومواجهه من العيار الثقيل
يسعى من خلالها المنتخب الارجنتيني
والكرواتي الى تحقيق غايتهما ببلوغ
المباراه النهائيه لمونديال قطر
2022 في ملعب لوسيل مباراه مصيريه قد تغير
ميزان الكفه بين لاعبين محترفين
ارجنتينيين وفي مقدمتهم ميسي وكرواتيا
المقتزه باللاعبين القتاليين بقياده
مودريتش حيث ستكون هذه المواجهه الثالثه
بين الارجنتين وكرواتيا في كاس العالم
والاولى من نوعها في الادوار الاقصى
راقصوا التانجو هذه المره سيكونون امام
فرصه كبيره لكسر احت- احتكار القاره
العجوز لللقب منذ العام 2006 الهيمنه
المنتخبات الاوروبيه على النسخ الاربعه
الماضيه بتتويج ايطاليا عام 2006 اسبانيا
عام 2010 والمانيا في عام 2014 وفرنسا في
عام فين وثمانيه عشر فالمنتخب الارجنتيني
لطالم قدم مستويات ونتائج منطقيه وضعته
على راس المرشحين للفوز بالبطوله قبل
بدايتها وقد وصل الى نصف النهائي بعد ما
اطاح بالمنتخب الهولندي بركلات الترجيح في
الربع النهائي بينما اثبتت كرواتيا انها
من الكبار بعدما كانت طرفا في نهائي
مونديال النسخه الماضيه لتعود وتبلغ نصف
نهائي مونديال الدوحه بعد اطاحتها
بالعملاق البرازيلي في الربع النهائي وفقه
مراقبين مشاهدينا جميعا على الاحتمالات
متاحه في مواجهه اليوم حيث يتطلع المنتخب
الارجنتيني للوصول لنهائي كاس العالم
للمره السادسه اما المنتخب الكرواتي فقد
يكون رابع منتخب اوروبي يصل للنهائي في
مرات متتاليه بعد طبعا ايطاليا وهولندا
والمانيا
[موسيقى]
ايضا في نصف نهائي كاس العالم اسود الاطلس
يبحثون عن صناعه التاريخ في المباراه التي
ستجمع المنتخب المغربي مع نظيره الفرنسي
غدا حيث يخطط الاسود لمواصله لمغامره
الموندياليه وحجز مكان في النهائي بعد ما
اقصى البرتغال في الربع النهائي بينما
تسعى فرنسا للحفاظ على لقبها ومنذ انطلاق
المونديال كانت الصراعات الثنائيه بارزه
حيث تالق الحارسان ياسين بونو المغربي
في الادوار السابقه وساهم بشكل كبير في
المشوار الجيد الذي كتبه المنتخبات كما
سيكون صراع ثنائي بين حكيمي وما با-ابرس
في مباراه الغد لعده اعتبارات
الصداقه القويه التي تربطهما والاضواء
التي تطارد الاثنين باعتبار وجودهما معا
في باريس سان جيرمان وسيكون هناك ايضا
صراع ثنائي مهم بين غانم سايس دافع وقائد
الاسود والمهاجم الفرنسي اوليفيا غو وحيث
سيكون مطالبا بمراقبته خصوصا وانغو يعتبر
واحدا من ابرز نقاط القوه الهجوميه
للمنتخب الفرنسي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الحديث اكثر عن هذه المباراه
المنتظره
حمزه ادريس اللاعب السعودي الدولي السابق
اهلا وسهلا بك يعني الفريقين تواجها خمس
مرات
مرتين ربحت كرواتيا مرتين
الارجنتين وطبعا هناك مره تعادل اليوم
ملحوظ لكل الفريقين بصراحه يعني نتكلم عن
المباراه للطرفين موجوده في التنظيم
الدفاع واللعب كم مجموعه المنتخب كرواتيا
وموجوده في اللحظه الابداعيه اللي تكون
عند ميسي اليوم لو كان في افضل حالاته هو
قادر ينقل المباراه النهائيه مقابل
التنظيم القوي في في في الجانب الكرواتي
اللعبه الجماعي
سحب المباراه للاوقات الاضافيه او حتى
ركلات الترجيح فاعتقد انها هتكون 50 50
بينجحون بهذا التكتيك الليله ممكن بالنسبه
للكروات هذه فرصتهم هيكون اكثر تفكير اللي
هو انه يسحب المباراه
كاس العالم 2018
كرواتيا يعني المعروف ان خط الوسط هو نقطه
قوه الفريق
والارجنتين لديها ميسي هذا هو يعني هو
النقطه الاساسيه والنقطه القوه الاساسيه
هل يعني ستسمح او سيستطيع ميسي اختراق خط
الوسط بصراحه دائما في كره القدم اللاعب
المبدع هو مبدع عشان هذه الاشياء انه هو
قادر انه اليوم يطلع بحاجه لو شفنا تمريره
وامامه هولندا وتمريره سحريه تمريره
خياليه في كره القدم ههه نحن بنتفرج في
التلفزيون يعني مش عارفين كيف هو مسافر
لاعب ومره له التمريره هذا ميسي ميسي مهما
كان عليه رقابه مهما كان في تكتلات وهو
قادر يصنعها اهم شيء انه يكون في افضل
حالات الضغط النفسي حاله هيكون عليه كبير
لانه يعني اخر فرصه لميسي ان هو يحقق كاس
همم
يعني نحن منتظرين ابداعات ميسي
همم مودريتش
انا اتوقع لا نحن منتظرين مواجهه ميسي
الشكل الجماعي اليوم كاس العالم هذه
اعطانا انه الفرق اللي بتلعب بالشكل
الجماعي شفنا المغرب كرواتيا هي اللي
عندها فرص وعندها حظوظ انهم يوصلوا لابعد
نقطه
المباراه
واضح هذه الفريقين توصل لنصف نهائي كل
فريق عارف نقاط القوه ونقاط الضعف همم
المباراه زي كذا هتكون اكيد مغلقه ما
هتكون مفتوحه
والاعتماد على التحولات مقابل هذا
الارجنتين هيكون عندهم ضغط عالي في في
مناطق كرواتيا ومحاوله محاوله اكتساب لحظه
خلل في التنظيم الدفاع للفريق الكرواتي
وتسجيل الهدف يعني اتوقع انها هتكون
هجوميه ارجنتينيه مقابل دفاع وتحولات
واللعب على الهجمه المرتده يعني
ان التنبؤ صعب ولكن
برايك او بهيك احساسك لهذلك اضافيه
اذا امتدت للاشواط الاضافيه وركبات
الترجيح
كرواتيهم يجدوا يجدوا التعامل مع بعض ال90
دقيقه الكرات اكثر تعامل اقوى في الناحيه
البدنيه عندهم حارس مميز في صدر ركلات
الترجيح عندهم الثقه والايمان اذا وصل
الاضافيه هيكون عندهم الجانب النفسي اقوى
من الفريقتين شكرا لك يا حمزه
ويشهد مشاهدينا مونديال قطر 2022 حضورا
نسائيا كبيرا حيث ارتفعت نسبه حضور النساء
في مدرجات الملاعب الى 65% التفاصيل مع
الزميل ليث باثاري
لم تعد مباريات كره القدم حكرا على الذكور
فامونديال قطر 2022 يشهد حضور النسائيا
كبيرا في مدرجات ملاعبه فقد رصد ارتفاعا
بنسبه 65% للجنس اللطيف من الفتيات
اللواتي اصبحنا يتابعنا المنتخبات
ولاعبيها فمنهم من تشارك في الهدافات
ومنهم ان ترتدي الوان فريق بلدها او
المنتخب المفضل لديها
في حياتي الى جانب الالعاب الاولمبيه وهو
كاس مميز لانه يقام في بلد رائع ومختلف
دائما في المونديال وكثير من النساء في
الارجنتين يقولون بذلك
امر طبيعي بالنسبه لنساء بلدي
صغير وكره القدم تشعرنا بالسعاده ولوكا
مودريتش يجعلنا سعداء اكثر من اي شيء
منتخبات المغرب والارجنتين والبرازيل لها
حصه الاسد من المشجعه فلن تتردد مشجعات
تلك المنتخبات بالظهور وهن يرتدين قمصان
منتخب وسط الدوحه في سوق واقف ومنتخب شارب
واللؤلؤه والكورنيش وحتى في محيط الملاعب
التي تقام على اراضيها المباريات الختاميه
للحصول على كاس عالم كره القدم هذا العام
الذي وحد العرب والعربيات حول اللعبه
الاكثر شعبيه في العالم
العربيه الدوحه دوله قطر
زينسكي للغرب قطاع الطاقه باوكرانيا بحاجه
ل 800 مليون دولار او يورو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد رغم التنديد والتحذير
يواصل النظام الايراني سياسه التصعيد
والترهيب لقمع الاحتجاجات التي دخلت شهرها
الثالث في البلاد فبعد تنفيذ الاعدام
الثانيه حكم القضاء الايراني في طهران على
400 شخص بالسجن لمده تصل الى 10 سنوات
لمشارتهم في الاحتجاجات هذا وكان رئيس
قضاه محافظه طهران علي القاسي قال في
جلسات الاستماع الخاصه بقضايا مسير الشهب
في طهران انه حكم على 160 شخص بالسجن لمده
تتراوح بين خمس و10 سنوات وعلى 80 شخصا
بالسجن من سنتين الى خمس سنوات و160 شخصا
لمده تصل الى عامين طبعا نقلت وسائل
الاعلام ايرانيه
اعلن الاتحاد الدولي للاعبي كره القدم
المحترفين ان لاعب كره القدم الايراني
امير نصر ازاداني يواجه الاعدام في بلاده
بسبب احتجاجه على النظام جاء هذا في
تغريده على حساب الذي نادى بالغاء القرار
وعبر الاتحاد عن صدمته من الحكم
في غضون ذلك توعد وزير الامن الايراني
اسماعيل الخطيب بانزال العقاب بحق اي شخص
يشارك بالاحتجاجات الشعبيه في ايران في اي
مكان في العالم وفقا وكاله تسليم
الايرانيات وكانت صحيفه التلغراف نسبه
الشهر الماضي الى المدير العام للمخابرات
البريطانيه الداخليه قوله ان طهران خطط
لخطف واغتيال 10 مقيمين في بريطانيا
تتهممهم بانهم اعداء للنظام كما نقلت هيئه
البث الكنديه عن المخابرات الكنديه قولها
ان لديها تقارير موثوقه عن تحديدات
ايرانيه بالقتل ضد افراد داخل كندا
هذا وقالت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه في رد
على سؤال العربيه ان قمع ايران الوحشي
للمتظاهرين لا يسهل العلاقه معها كما وصف
رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا في رد ايضا لسؤال
العربي على هامشي مؤتمر دعم اوكرانيا في
باريس وصف ايران بالشريكه في جرائم الحرب
التي ترتكبها روسيا وقال انه يجب محاسبه
ايران على تورطها في الحرب او محاسبه
روسيا
[موسيقى]
مين امستردام ينضم الينا عبر سكايب يعقوب
سعيد الباحث في الشان الايراني استاذ
يعقوب يعني بعد سنوات من بدايه حكم
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه بدات عمليه تصفيه
المعارضين في الخارج والذين يتم وصفهم
باعداء النظام ثم تراجعت بعهد الاصلاح
خاتمي الى انها ايضا فعلت اسرى الثوره
الخضراء اليوم اعاده تفعيله وبقوه وعبر
تصريحات رسميه هل ممكن ان يؤثر على زخم
التظاهرات في الداخل
الصوت كان المتقطع عندي ممكن اعاده السؤال
اليوم
الذهاب الى اغتيالات في الخارج هل ممكن ان
تؤثر على زخم التظاهرات في الداخل خصوصا
انه تاريخيا كانت يعني
او اوقات تفعلها النظام يفعلها النظام
الايراني واوقات تخوفنا
قناه العربيه بكل تاكيد يعني النظام
الايراني يمتلك فرقه موت وهذا لم يعد خفيا
همم خاصه الحرس الثوري يمتلك فرقه موت
مخصصه للاغتيال وتسهيل عمليات الاغتيال في
الخارج النشاطات النظام الايراني دائما ما
يهدد ان الخطا في الخارج من خلال الاوائل
في الداخل في اختيالهم التصور بانه اي اا
اي اختيالات في الخارج سوف تنعكس كان
مباشر على الاحتياجات في داخل كما كما كما
تنعكس اليوم الاختيالات في الداخل يعني
بالتالي عمليات الاعدام هذا شكل من اشكال
الاغتيال من قبل النظام الايراني ونرى بان
هذه عمليه الاعدام هذه تنعكس بشكل مباشر
على المحتاجين من خلال المشاركه في
الجنازه او حتى همم ترديد اسماء المحتاجين
وحتى انتشار عملي ال- ال- الاحتجاجات بشكل
اوسع بعد عمليات بعد عمليات الاعدام او
بعد الاغتيالات التي تحصل سواء في الشارع
او في السجون بكل تاكيد نعم
المعارضه الخارجيه الاراديه هي مزيج من
الاختلاف الاثني وايضا الطائفي وايضا مزيج
من الاختلاف حول حول طريقه النظام ان كان
عبر المسار السياسي او عبر المسار المسلح
اليوم مسار الشارع هو السائد هل يعني هناك
خوف عند النظام من التقاء المعارضه على
دعم الشارع كسبي الوحيد لاسقاط النظام
الايراني خلال السنوات الماضيه خلال
العقود الماضيه على تفرقه هذه القوميات في
ايران على زرع مثلا هنالك اختلافات كبيره
من خلال التداخل السكاني بين الاقراض
والاذريين وكذلك بين العرب وكذلك بين
العرب والفرس والعكس
النظام الايراني عمل على هذه الاختلافات
واحتاج من خلال هذه الاختلافات التي عاده
ما يستفاد من
النظام الايرانيه الان متخوف جدا من
التقاء مصالح هذه القوميات في اسقاط جميع
تقريبا جميع احزاب المعارضه او معظمه
مختلفه اليوم اصبح لديهم وعي وهذا منعطف
بتصور منعطف يعني تاريخي في في في تاريخ
نضال هذه القوميات في ايران هو
همم نقطه وحيده ان نشترك في اسقاط النظام
وهذه النقطه الان اصبح الجميع واعلى
هوالجميع يشترك بها بانه عمليه اسقاط
النظام هي تجمعنا ولا تفرقنا ما بعد عمليه
اسقاط النظام نتركها للظروف التي تتيح هذه
يعني ما بعد ما بعد اسقاط النظام
بالفتره الماضيه كان هناك تشابك مصالح بين
بعض الدول الداعمه للمعارضه في الخارج
والنظام الايراني وايضا تشابك مصالح
وتشابك رؤيه بين النظام وبعض دول اخرى
بضروره تحجيم المعارضه هل اليوم يعني هناك
همم تغيير وخصوصا بعد انسداد الطرق بين
النظام وبين المجتمع الدولي
بكل تاكيد حتى هذه الدول ايضا كانت متخوفه
من هذا التفرق لدى المعارضه لان هم مثلا
كانوا يتخوفون من عدم وجود بديل في حال
اسقاط النظام عدم وجود بديل في ظل
التفرقات الاختلافات التي كانت موجوده
لديها هذه القوميات ولكن هذا هذا ال- ال-
التوحد لدى هذه الشعوب جميعا يعطي اعطى
رسائل فعلا الى الى هذه الدول باننا
قادرين على تغيير هذا النظام باننا قادرين
ان نشكل بديلا حقيقيا وديمقراطيا يج- يسعد
تحسين على الاقل او لحفظ مصالح الدول
الغربيه في ايران وبالتالي
تشكيل دوله ديمقراطيه خارج عن عن هذه
الدوله الدينيه التي دائما عملت على
معادله الغرب ونشر نظريات المؤامره على
المستوى الداخلي بتصوري
هذه الدول الغربيه
وهو يعني واضح عبر العقوبات وعبر
التصريحات الرسميه شكرا لك يا استاذ يعقوب
سعيد البحث في الشان الايراني حدثنا من
امستردام
في ايران ايضا لكن بموضوع اخر ذكرت وكالات
ايرنا للانباء ان رئيس الايراني ابراهيم
رئيسي ابلغناء رئيس الوزراء الصيني ان بعض
المواقف الرئيس شيت جنبيك خلال زيارته
للمنطقه اثارت استياء بلاده واضافته
الوكاله ان نائب رئيس الوزراء الصيني ابلغ
رئيسي بان الصين كانت ولا تزال تحترم
ايران ووحده اراضيها
[موسيقى]
الى الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث تبادلت القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه القصب بشكل كثيف
بمنطقه دنياس وتسعى موسكو الانتزاع
السيطره على اقليم بس بشكل كامل عبر زوج
المزيد من القوات العسكريه على جبهتي دنيا
اعلنت القوات الاخرانيه انها تصدت لعده
محاولات اختراق روسيه على اطراف
[موسيقى]
نقلات صحيفه تايمز عن جنرال بريطانيا قوله
ان القوات البحريه الملكيه البريطانيه
شاركت في عمليات سريه شديده الحساسيه
باوكرانيا وقال الجنرال البريطاني الذي
نقلت عنه تايمز ان العمليه السريه التي
شاركت بها القوات البحريه الملكيه كانت
على درجه عاليه من المخاطر السياسيه
والعسكريه
بالمقابل وعبر الجواسيس باتت بعض الدول
الاوروبيه هدفا لاختراق روسي محتمل وفقا
لنيويورك تايمز التي كشفت عن ان روسيا
ولتخفيف وطاه خسارتها في الحرب اوكرانيا
ستسعى لاستغلال المجتمعات الاوروبيه
المفتوحه لتعميق محاولات التجسس والتخريب
لايصال رسائل معينه وكانت النرويج قد
اوقفت في وقت سابق رجلا بتهمه التجسس
العسكري لصالح روسيا وقبلها اوقفت اوسلو
ايضا سبعه مواطنين روس داخل اراضيها بعد
اتهامهم باطلاق مسيرات مشبوهه في النرويج
اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان المؤتمر
الدولي الذي استضافته باريس لدعم اوكرانيا
اتاح جامعه بحوالي مليار يورو لمساعده
السكان في تحمل فصل الشتاء بعد ما ضربت
روسيا معظم منشات الطاقه في البلاد واوضحت
انه من اصل مبلغ المليار يورو سيخصص 415
مليون لقطاع الطاقه 25 مليون للمياه 38
مليون للغذاء و 17 مليون صحه و 22 مليون
لوسائل النقل من جانبه قال الرئيس
الاوكراني
بحاجه الى 800 مليون يورو على الاقل
كمساعدات طارئه لقطاع الطاقه لتربيه
احتياجات السكان خلال فصل الشتاء
يكون فرنسي
800 مليون يورو انه كثير لكن السعر اقل
بكثير من تكلفه انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
بالنسبه لنا في اوكرانيا لذلك ادعوكم الى
انهاء هذا المؤتمر بالاتفاق على جميع
القرارات لدعم اوكرانيا بامدادات الطاقه
من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي الالاف من
الشركات الاوكرانيه والشركات الصغيره
ومتوسطه الحجم والخدمات الاجتماعيه تواصل
العمل بفضل المولدات كما تعمل المستشفيات
ايضا بالمولدات التي ايضا بفضلها تم انقاذ
مئات الالاف من الوظائف والحفاظ على تغطيه
الانترنت وشبكه الهاتف
[موسيقى]
اعلن سلاح الجويه الامريكيه عن اطلاق
صاروخ كروز فرد صوتي من قاذفه ب 52 تفوق
سرعته سرعه الصوت بخمسه اضعاف وقال بان
التجربه الامريكيه جاءت في اطار برنامج
الولايات المتحده للاسلحه الاسرع من الصوت
والتي قامت بتجارب سابقه على مثل هذه
الصواريخ في اطار المنافسه بينها وبين
الصين وروسيا كما ان الخطوه الامريكيه
جاءت فيما دخلت كوريا الشماليه خط الاسلحه
الخارقه والتي دفعت طبعا واشنطن الى
التحذير من هذا النوع من الاسلحه التي لا
تلتقطها اجهزه الاستشعار
[موسيقى]
صاروخ وفرط صوتي امريكي يدخل حلقه التنافس
الدائره بين الولايات المتحده والصين
وروسيا على صعيد التقنيه العسكريه
المتطوره صاروخ كروز اي جي ام هو اول
نموذج لصاروخ فرط صوتي امريكي يتميز
بقدرته على ايصال شحنات نوويه بدقه الى
هدفها المحدد بسرعه فرض صوتيه صواريخ
المصممه للطيران بسرعه عاليه والتي قد
تتجاوز سرعتها 15,000 في الساعه ثم تطوير
مركبه الانزلاق المعزز الخاصه بها من طرف
شركه لوكيد مارتن دي قيمه ماليه قدرت نحو
480 مليون دولار المركبه المطوره يتم
دفعها الى سرعه قصوى تزيد عن خمسه ماج او
خمسه اضعاف
تسمح للصاروخ بتغيير اتجاهه اثناء التحليق
ما يجعل اعتراض هذا الصاروخ اكثر صعوبه
وفقا طبعا للسلاح الجو الامريكي فلق تم
تصميم الصاروخ للاحتفاظ باهداف ثابته
وعاليه القيمه القادره على المناوله
الجويه والمصممه خصيصا للافلات من اجهزه
الاستشعار مما يعني انه سيتم استخدام هذا
الصاروخ لاستهداف المواقع المحدده مسبقا
على الارض كما حطات الرادار او منشات
الدفاع الجوي او مرافق البنيه التحتيه يتم
حمل صاروخ اي جي ام تحت جناح طائره قبل
اطلاقها ثم يشتعل معزز صاروخي صلب ويرفع
الصاروخ كما نشاهدون الى ارتفاع وسرعه
محددين قبل ان تفتح فتحات الحموله الصافيه
وتحرر مركبه الانزلاق المعزز على عكس طبعا
الصواريخ البالستيه التقليديه بحسب موقع
ديفانس نيوز فانا الولايات المتحده اعطت
الاولويه لتطوير اسلحه تفوق سرعه الصوت في
السنوات الاخيره وتمكنت من انشاء انظمه
اسلحه جديده بكفاء غير مسبوقه كجزء طبعا
من برنامج التحديث العسكري لسلاح الرد
السريع المطلق من الجوع
[موسيقى]
التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
في اطار قضيه فتحي باشا يطالب واشنطن
بتوضيح اعتقالها لابو عجيله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في جميع انحاء بريطانيا
شلل شبه تام واضطراب حقيقيه لوح في الافق
لمده شهر كامل والسبب هو امتناع عمال
السكك الحديديه عن العمل وفق تقرير صادر
عن صحيفه الجاردين بريطانيا فان عمال
السكك الحديديه تركوا وظائفهم وخاضوا
اضرابا عاما متسببين في تعطيل 80% من حركه
القطارات والغاء العديد من الرحلات والسما
مخاوف كبيره من طرف حكومه صنعاء التي وجدت
نفسها عاجزه امام هاجس الاضطرابات
المتكرره التي تشهدها البلاد منذ العام
الماضي والتي يمكن ان تستمر هذه المره في
شهر كامل بسبب تراجع طبعا المستوى المعيشي
وتدهور القدره الشرائيه والتي دفعت
بالعشرات من الموظفين في بريطانيا
للمطالبه برفع الاجور خصوصا بريطانيا تشهد
ارقاما قياسيه في معدلات التضخم حيث بلغت
اعلى مستوياتها خلال 41 عاما بوصول معدلات
التضخم الى ما يقارب 11%
قميصه
لا يتقاضون رواتبهم مقابل اضرابتهم ايضا
لذا فهذا يعني الكثير
للغايه لكن من الصعب جدا موازنه ذلك ولست
متاكدا تماما من الاستنتاج الذي يمكن
استخلاصه انهم يقاتلون من اجل رفاهيتهم
وسبل عيشهم يا امين
لكنني في النهايه اؤيد حقهم في الاضراب
تماما وان لديهم الاسباب للقيام بذلك
وسائل الاعلام بريطانيه اكدت بان حمى
الاضرابات في طريقها الاجتياح قطاعات اخرى
وليس فقط قطاع النقل والجو حيث من المقرر
ان يبدا الممرضون وقوات حرس الحدود وسائقه
سيارات الاسعاف الى جانب موظفي قطاعات
اخرى اضرابا هذا الشهر اضرابات وضعت
الحكومه في موقف محرج ما دفعها طبعا الى
التفكير في مناقشه تعبئه الجيش لتوفير
الخدمات العامه الحيويه بالتزامن مع فصل
الشتاء وتحسبا لازمه الطاقه التي تشهدها
البلاد وتاتي حمله الاضطرابات هذه في
توقيت الحساس من السنه حيث تتزامن مع فتره
اعياد الميلاد ما قد يؤثر على موسم
الاحتفالات السنويه في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
معنى من لندن راتب سليمان العضو السابق في
حزب المحافظين البريطاني استاذ راتب يعني
هذه الموجه من الاحتجاجات التي لم تشهدها
بريطانيا منذ عقد من الزمن كيف يمكن
للحكومه ان تصمت بوجه المطالبه الشعبيه
الكبيره وكيف يمكن للبلد اقتصاديا ان تصمت
بالمرحله
اه طبعا مساء الخير لكم وللمشاهدين الكرام
بريطانيا اليوم تمر بازمه صعبه للغايه
السكك الحديد والقطارات اضرابات وكذلك
التمريض وكذلك
القطاع البريد جميع القطاعات العماليه
الان بدات بالاضرابات وهذه الاضرابات بدات
من اليوم وستبقى هذا الاسبوع لمده اربعه
ايام
همم غدا همم وبعد غد وبعد غد ثلاثه ايام
اخرى هذه الاضرابات طبعا ستكون همم صعبه
جدا بالنسبه للحكومه وبالنسبه للشعب
البريطاني لان نعلم في هذه الايام هنا
اعياد الميلاد وفي اعياد الميلاد هذه
الايام تكون ايام خاصه بالنسبه للشعب
البريطاني فهناك العديد من
العائلات او الناس تريد الذهاب للتسوق
وتريد الذهاب لزياره اقاربهم وهذا الان
طبعا سيكون صعب جدا بالنسبه للمواطن همم
من المعلوم ان السياسه المحافظين وهو ما
ايضا يعني استفاضت به الصحف البريطانيه
سياسه المحافظين ادت الى تنام الفجر بين
رواتب القطاع العام والقطاع الخاص اليوم
يعني صعدت رواتب القطاع خاص مقابل تراجع
رواتب القطاع العام هذا كيف سيؤثر شعبيه
على الحزب كيف سيؤثر على القدره الشرائيه
ايضا للمواطنين وهل بصفاتهم اخذ قرارات
شعبويه
طبعا حزب المحافظين دوما همم يساعد او
يكون مع ال
مع التجاره ومع الاغنياء هذه هي السياسه
حزب المحافظين ولكن هناك حقوق لهؤلاء
الجهه العماليه هناك لهم حقوق على الدوله
يجب ان تضمن لهم عيشه كريمه وهمم اجر همم
جيد الان غلاء الاسعار في بريطانيا
والامور اصبحت صعبه لدفع الفواتير لذلك
هؤلاء الناس محقين في مطالبهم ومطالبهم
محقه طلبوا بزياده الاجور بما يقارب 19%
همم كان هناك طبعا اجتماعات سابقه بينهم
وبين الحكومه بين النقابات طبعا همم اعضاء
النقابه العماليه
لم يتوصلوا الى النتيجه
المرض وليس يعني العوارض هل ما الذي يمكن
ان تقوم به الحكومه بهذا الصدد
الحكومه الان تطالب في ااا
تطالب في ادخال الجيش للمساعده في
بالنسبه
للتمريض او بالصحه سيقوم الجيش همم
باستخدام سيارات الاسعاف
وسيكون هناك طبعا همم تدريب لهؤلاء
همم الجيش او العساكر اذا لحالات الاسعاف
اذا كان هناك اي اصحاب لان الامور خطيره
جدا طبعا بريطانيا لا تريد ان يكون هناك
اي ضحيه بالنسبه لهذه الازرابات طبعا
سيكون هناك الكثير من المرضى الذين يريدون
الذهاب الى المستشفيات واذا كان هناك اي
همم لا سمح الله الضحيه او شيء سيكون
سيتحمل مسؤوليتها بعض الناس او بعض
المسؤولين في الحكومه لذلك ستحاول الحكومه
قدر الامكان هذا في ااا تجنب هذا الشيء هو
كذلك بالنسبه للعمال كذلك لا يريدون ان
يحصل ذلك سيحاولون قدر الامكان بان
يعملوا همم جاهدين لكي تكون الامور
تمشي على ما يرام ولكن بكل الاحوال
على ابواب الاعياد شكرا لك استاذ راتب
سليمان العضو السابق في حزب المحافظين
البريطانيا
[موسيقى]
لم تدعي على الاتفاقات الاحتلافيه التي
توصل اليها الثانيه هما احزاب اليمين
المتطرف ما شالا كبيرا للشك في ان خطه ضمه
الضفه الغربيه لاسرائيل قد تصبح واقعيه
حيث سيصبح حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه مسؤولا
عما يسمى بالاداره المدنيه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي فيما سيسيطر المتطرف اليمني
على حرص الحدود في الضفه الغربيه وبين هذا
وذاك مررت واشنطن تحذيرا مسبقا لنتارينه
بانها لم تتعاطى مع وزراء متطرفين او
يمنيين محذره من
خطر مشاريعهم وتصرفاتهم
مشروع اليمين الاسرائيلي لبناء دوله
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه المحتله ومنع
دوله للفلسطينيين اخذ دفعه عمليه ومعنويه
مصادره الاداره المدنيه التابعه للجيش
الاسرائيلي من يد وزير الدفاع واعطائها
لحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه الاستيطانيه
المتطرف لا يضع القطه في حراسه اللبن فقط
وفق مراقبين بل يحول محاولات ضم الضفه
لاسرائيل من زاحفه الى سريعه
للمستوطنين وهي محاوله لاحاله القانون
الاسرائيليه على المستوطنين في المناطق
الفلسطينيه بدون ضمن الحالي لهذا هناك
معارضه قويه من المؤسسات الامنيه لتبيعات
ذلك ميدانيا وقانونيا دبلوماسيه
خطه العمل لحزب المستوطنين هي تكثيف
البناء الاستيطاني في المستوطنات القائمه
وتحويل اكثر من 70 بؤره شيطانيه عشوائيه
الى مستوطنات تتبناها الحكومه الى جانب
حمله هدم واسعه النطاق للبناء الفلسطيني
في مناطق الجيم تمهيدا لضمها ما قد يفجر
ازمه مع الاداره الامريكيه والمجتمع
الدولي فضلا عن تفجير الوضع الميداني اكثر
المرحله القادمه هي مرحله صعبه يركز فيها
اليمين المتطرف الذي سوف يحكم اسرائيل على
على الضم وعلى التهويت في داخل مدينه
القدس وايضا على توزيع مخططات الظلام
ناسيه مع ان هناك اصوات من الوزراء
القادمين همم ينادون لتشكيل وزاره مختصره
لتاجير الفلسطينيين وفقا للقانون الدولي
لا سياده الاسرائيل على ضفه الغربيه
والقدس الشرقيه وتسيطر عليها بعمليه
قتاليه مؤقته اي ان وزير الدفاع
يدير الوضع لهذا فان ادخال السيطره
المدنيه للحكومه رسميه تعني بدء الضم
الفعلي للضفه الغربيه في حكومه متطرفه
يبدو فيها نتنياهو الجناح اليسريه سيشهد
مشروع الاستيطان انتعاشا وتمددا الى جانب
المعالجه الامنيه الاسرائيليه فقط للقضيه
الفلسطينيه بحيث لا تتسع خريطه الواقع
لقيام دوله فلسطينيه ما قد ينهي حل
للدولتين كما تخشى دوائر استراتيجيه في
اسرائيل اما الى قيام نظام ابارتيد او الى
دوله ثانيه القوميه زياد حلبي العربيه
الضفه الغربيه المحتله
[موسيقى]
طلب رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلفه من
البرلمان فتحي باشا من السلطات الامريكيه
ايضاح كيفيه وصول مواطنه ابو عجيله مسعود
الى واشنطن في اطار قضيه الاقربين ونقل
التلفزيون
خطف خارج الاطار القانوني والقضائي
والشرعي
اصدر الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
قرارا بشان تحديدا الحدود البحريه الغربيه
لمصر في البحر المتوسط الماده الاولى من
القرار على ان تبدا حدود البحر الاقليميه
لمصر من نقطه الحدود البريه المصريه
الليبيه وسيتم الاعلان عن قوائم
الاحداثيات الوارده بالماده الاولى من هذا
القرار وفقا للقواعد المعمول بها في هذا
الصدد وسيتم اخطار الامين العام للامم
المتحده بها
[موسيقى]
في اطار او في سوريا جمله لم يعد هناك
اسوء مما نعيشه الان هذه الجمله لا تفارق
شفاه السوريين من من يقتلون مناطق نظام
الاسد فبعد ازمه المزود او المحروقات
عموما ها هي ازمه جديده تطال سفره
السوريين هذه المره وهي مشكله توفر ماده
الخبز بعد ما توقف نحو 50 بالمئه من
الافران عن العمل في العاصمه دمشق اصحاب
مخابز خاصه رئيسيه بدمشق اكدوا على عدم
قدرتهم في الاستمرار بالعمل لان الاستمرار
يعني مزيدا من الخسائر بعد ما خفض النظام
من حصه هذه المخابز بنسبه 40% وبالتالي
ارتفاع كبير باسعار المازوت من السوق
السوداء لتشكل هذه الازمه او هذا الكابوس
ان سحب تعبير الاسوء على السوريين منذ عام
2011 ومع اشتداد الازمه وافتقاد الماده
توقف نحو 50% من الافران الخاصه عن العمل
في دمشق و30% خفضت الانتاج و20% لا تشتري
المحروقات ولكن طبعا باسعار مرتفعه
[موسيقى]
اعلانات الامم المتحده ان انعدام الامن
الغذائي في الصومال لم يصل حد المشاعاعه
الا ان عدت مناطق في البلاد عرضه للخطر
ولخطر المجاعه خلال الاشهر القادمه وفق
تقريرا للامم المتحده التقرير حذر من ان
اكثر من 8 ملايين شخص يعانون انعدام الامن
الغذائي بتزامني مع الجفاف وغلاء اسعار
الغذاء كما اشار الى المجاعه المتوقعه في
مناطق جنوب غرب الصومال وبين النازحين ما
يعرض 700,000 شخص لخطر المجاعه في تلك
المناطق
رسومات رسومات
لا يعني اعلان المجاعه في هذه المرحله الا
ان الازمه لم تتحسن اذا لم يتم توسيع نطاق
المساعده من المتوقع ان تحدث المجاعه بين
ابريل ويونيو من العام المقبل ويظهر
التقرير ان الازمه ستتوسع ويتم حاليا
تصنيف ثمانيه ملايين و300,000 شخص في
المرحله الثالثه لتصنيف الدولي ومليونين
و700,000 شخص في الحاله الرابعه
[موسيقى]
مجموعه شامله من اللوائح اقرتها الولايات
المتحده في اكتوبر تهدف الى تقييد صناعه
اشباه الموصلات في الصين وفي خطوه جديده
في ملف الرقائق الالكترونيه تخطط الصين
لضخ استثمارات جديده في صناعتها لتحقق
اهدافها في هذا المشغل
143 مليار دولار في صناعه الرقائق
الالكترونيه في خطوه لتحقيق الاكتفاء
الذاتي من حزمه اشباه الموصلات والمواجهه
التحركات الامريكيه تستهدف ابطاء التقدم
التكنولوجي الصينيه
حوافز لمده خمس سنوات واعانات وقروض لدعم
الابحاث وانتاج اشباه الموصلات
خطه تقييد صناعه اشباه الموصلات في الصين
التي اقرتها الولايات المتحده في اكتوبر
دفعت وزاره التجاره الصينيه لاطلاق النزاع
التجاري في منظمه التجاره العالميه ضدها
موازنه عاليه جدا خصصتها الصين منذ
البدايه تضاهي تلك الامريكيه
فبكين تسعى من اجل رفع حصتها السوقيه
لتبلغ 70 بالمئه بحلول عام 2025 وان كانت
التوقعات لا تمنحها سوى 40 بالمئه كحد
اقصى
ونوهت مجله فرن افيرز انه ينبغي على الصين
انتاج رقائق متقدمه بجيلين او ثلاثه فقط
عن الشركات الرائده في تايوان وكوريا
الجنوبيه لبلوغ هدفها المنشود ما يعني
انها ستحتاج الى ما لا يقل عن خمس الى عشر
سنوات للحاق بركب تطور التكنولوجي
فبحسب خبراء ابرز ما يعيقه تقدم بكين في
مجال صناعه اشباه الموصلات اعتمادها
المفرط على استيراد مستلزمات الانتاج من
الموردين الامريكيين والتايوانيين
والكوريين الجنوبيين واليابانيين الى جانب
افتقارها الى المعرفه اللازمه اذ لا تزال
تعتمد على المواهب الاجنبيه في المسائل
التقنيه
مجابهه الفتحاتها الولايات المتحده بوجه
الصين منذ عهد الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
ليطفوا على سطح المحيط الهادئ صراع جديد
طرفه الاول تحالف امريكي اسيوي مع كوريا
الجنوبيه وتايوان واليابان لاقصاء الصين
من مستلزمات الانتاج لصناعه الرقائق اما
طرفه الثاني الصين وشركات التكنولوجيا
المحليه
مع العناوين
في اولى مباريات نصف نهائي المونديال بعد
لحظات الارجنتين بمهاره ميسي تواجه
كرواتيا بخبرات مودريتش
طهران تحكموا على مئات المتظاهرين بالسجن
طويلا وتتواعد بملاحقه زعم الاحتجاجات حول
العالم
شجره بريطانيه يكشفوا عن مشاركه بحريه
بلاده في عمليات عسكريه الى جانب اوكرانيا
ضد روسيا
[موسيقى]
الاقصى منذ عشر سنوات اضرابات كبيره تشوي
المفاصل بريطانيا والجيش ياخذ وضعيه
العمال
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى الزميلا
راويه راويه اهلا بك يا ليال طبعا الاخبار
الرياضيات طاغيه على الاغلب النشرات
والمباراه بدات الان بين الارجنتين
وكرواتيا سنتابع اجوائها مع تمنيات الخاصه
يعني بخساره الارجنتين وثمانيات ايضا كمال
لا انا حقد برازيلي